yesterday AT&T was cleared to purchase
Time Warner which technically makes AT&T
my new boss I just want to say two
things first this news will in no way
affect the content of my program and to
t-mobile sucks balls
yeah I hear sprints a bunch of
bed-wetters yeah
I heard that too Andy you know it's true
yeah what else is going on
a new report came out says that this
past year this is nice news this past
year was a record-breaking year for
Americans giving to charities in fact in
fact just yesterday President Trump gave
away South Korea very very generous it's
being a Trump yesterday present Trump
attacked Robert De Niro as someone this
is a quote who's received too many hits
to the head by real boxers yeah that was
all part of Trump's speech entitled I
don't understand how movies work look at
him he got hit I don't know oh you must
think Stallone is really funny yeah I
know I know interesting news the owner
of the famous bunnyranch brothel won the
primary for the Nevada State Legislature
yeah yeah one yeah he won on his strong
record of hiring women
[Applause]
the Detroit Zoo announce it sending
11,000 tadpoles to Puerto Rico to help
restore their native toad population
yeah yeah grateful Puerto Rico said
thanks but could you send some
electricity instead maybe a little
electricity and then I gotta mention
this on Tuesday a cow named char won the
sexiest cow in Britain award don't worry
the organizers of the contest have been
arrested
absolute freaks
you